hey it's our last show of the season
screw the rules
tonight i'd like to tell
tonight i'd like to tell you a tale of
dr william miller
the american preacher whose teaching
spawned the seventh day adventist
religion of today
in the 19th century miller grew an
enormous following by telling anyone
who'd listened that he could
by reading the bible and then applying
his own math
predict the exact date for the second
coming jesus's big return to show
business
which good news bad news also meant the
world would be coming to an end
so peaking in the early 1840s william
miller's rallies attracted thousands of
people
all focused on this one idea that the
world was going to end
on his predicted date of october 22 1844
that is the day the world would come to
an end spoiler alert it did not
christ totally blew them off
he was supposed to show up and just
flaked
typical
now when you stake your whole religion
on one
all-important prophecy that doesn't come
true the logical reaction from followers
should be
well i guess that was a bunch of
[ __ ]
but no no no no no
no this sect doubled down and to this
day
refers to october 22nd 1844 as
the great disappointment
because of course it's disappointing
when the world doesn't end
but the important thing is that you
didn't let your faith be shaken
in the guy who got it dead wrong
okay so by now you're saying
bill what the [ __ ] does this have to do
with what's going on in the world today
well recently there's been another large
group of people who had a great
disappointment
and will not accept their loss and the
challenge for us
is how do you get people out of a cult
especially when
every time you present evidence of what
is obvious reality
they take it as proof of you being in on
a conspiracy to destroy them
and for the answer to that question we
must turn to
and i'm sure many of you have already
guessed who i'm going to say now
catherine oxenburg
yes katherine oxenberg actress star of
dynasty european royalty and lady in
front of you at whole foods
catherine oxenburg because she got
somebody out of a cult
and i know about 70 million other
americans i'd like her to talk to
now if you don't know what i'm referring
to catherine oxenburg was recently
featured in not one but two
documentaries about a cult called nexium
that brainwashed her daughter india
nexium was led by a con man now serving
120 years named keith renery
aka vanguard that's the name he gave
himself vanguard
and as i was watching this documentary i
couldn't stop
thinking that ranieri i mean vanguard
reminded me of someone but i couldn't
put my finger on who
for example like most cult leaders
vanguard
had an extraordinary need to be
surrounded by ass lickers telling him
how great he was
has your being a part of my life
enhanced my life i don't have words to
tell you
how much it has a heartfelt tribute to
vanguard
you make it possible for us to grow
ourselves every day into the people that
we want to be
a very amazing man in many
many many ways who did that remind me of
i don't know that i've ever been more
proud to be standing next to you thank
you
president trump for allowing us to have
you as our president
you're living up to every everything i
thought you would
you're one heck of a leader oh yeah that
guy
that guy that's right
the one who was also always bragging
about what a genius he is
but i'm smarter than him i'm smarter
than anybody i'm a very stable genius
donald trump's very very large
a brain
well get this vanguard's followers
believed he was the demonstrably single
smartest person in the world because he
told them
he told them he spoke in full sentences
when he was one
and also that he invented his own math
just like dr william miller
and both trump's and vanguard's status
as cult leaders sprang from their
creation myths as
off the charts business savants when in
reality
vanguard's consumer byline business was
a pyramid scheme shut down by the state
of new york
and about as successful as the three
casinos trump drove into bankruptcy in
the 90s
oh and they both started fake schools
and then there's the fact that both men
were such unrepentant sex creeps
they literally could not stop themselves
from bragging about it
if we conquer a woman if we grab the
thing we want to [ __ ] whatever it is
and [ __ ] it and if we do whatever we
want
and they like it and when you're starved
they let you do it you can do anything
whatever you want
grab them by the [ __ ]
yeah you didn't notice that okay it
seemed rather parallel to me and like
all cult leaders they had to have that
one queen
bee around them who they deputized to
recruit others into their sick games
vanguard had smallville actress alison
mack
trump has lindsey graham
and you know when you're fighting a cult
you're not just fighting the leaders
but all the enablers who see you as an
enemy
truth is a threat to them that's why
what katherine oxenburg did was so
instructive you've heard the phrase hate
the sin
love the sinner well she practiced hate
the cult loved the cultist
she didn't scream at her daughter that
she was stupid she didn't cut her off
she just kept trying to remind her of
who she used to be
i think we need to try that on q anon
you know the ones who believe that rich
liberals are running a massive pedophile
ring and eat babies and in some cases
are really lizard people
wearing a human mask and they were
assured that trump was going to win
reelection as dr miller's followers were
that the world was going to end in
they were told to trust the plan that
trump would get a second
term devoted to busting the democratic
sex trafficking ring
but now on message boards we can see
they have doubt
and despondency one of them wrote my
faith is shaken
i followed the plan trump lost what now
what now opportunity to lift the scales
from their eyes
but it's not going to happen from
mocking them they're calling them stupid
or making smart remarks like if kamala
harris really is a lizard person
why didn't she eat that fly on mike
pence's head
don't do that i'm saying don't do that
no really
one more and then don't do it rather if
you have trump relatives over for
thanksgiving
understand they have been through a
traumatic event
their savior their strongest smartest
manliest hunk of a leader ever lived
just got his ass kicked by the 2000 year
old man
so
don't gloat don't even try to argue
because arguing with cult people
only makes it worse if there's hope
it's not in any of the words that were
communicated
it's in and so it is for me
to all of you in the audience thank you
so much who put up with so much just to
be here
all of the folks who helped make this
possible during this trying time
the crew who roll with it so well my
brilliant staff thank you all and
especially everyone at home
here's hoping for a better next year
couldn't have got through this one
without you
you